hey we're given four different functions
here and we want to find the domain see
if you can pause the video and do these
on your own we're gonna go through them
each problem is slightly different and I
want to show you some of the key things
to watch out for so for number one the
first thing that I notice here is that
we have a fraction and remember we
cannot divide by zero that's undefined
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take that denominator and I'm going to
factor it and set each factor equal to
zero so you can see here if I set X to
zero we know that X cannot equal zero
and if I set X minus four equal to zero
and add four to both sides we can see
that X cannot be four so the next thing
I want to do is I want to go to the
number line and I'm going to just plot
these from lowest to highest so we can
see that X cannot be zero it cannot be
four but it can be all these numbers all
of these numbers and all these values so
now we're going to do is we're going to
write it in interval notation the domain
is from negative infinity all the way up
to zero not including 0 Union 0 to 4
Union 4 to infinity and notice I'm using
the parenthesis because it doesn't
include those values and infinity you
can never reach infinity this is always
like an open use the parenthesis an open
interval so that's the domain for number
one so for number two we've got a square
root so how do we handle this square
root here well we know that we can't
take the square root of a negative
number we're going to have an imaginary
value so what we do is we say okay
whatever is underneath that square root
let's make an inequality let's make it
greater than or equal to zero greater
than zero means positive equal to zero
the square root of zero zero that's okay
we just don't want it to be negative so
now if I subtract 4 from both sides we
see that X has to be greater than or
equal to negative four so let's go to
our number line again here's negative 4
it's equal to negative 4 or greater so
when we write this in interval notation
notice that it includes negative 4 so
I'm using the bracket all the way to
infinity we can never reach infinity
that's an open that's a parenthesis so
that's our domain for number two for
number three you can see that we have a
square root again but it's in the
denominator so
similar to number two where you know we
had to make an inequality 2x minus three
is greater than zero but not equal to
zero because because it's in the
denominator we don't want to divide by
zero so it just has to be positive but
not zero so let's solve this inequality
by adding 3 to both sides let's divide
both sides by 2 so you can see X has to
be greater than 3 over 2 again I like to
just graph this on the number line so I
can kind of think about working from
left to right so we can see that it's
parenthesis 3 halves to infinity that's
our domain and then the last one number
4 you can see we've got a couple things
going on here we have a fraction so we
know the dynamic a not equal zero right
and we have a square root we can't take
the square root of a negative number so
we're combining them together the two
different things to watch out for so
here we can see that X cannot equal 1
and for the parenthesis we can see that
I'm sorry the square root 2 minus X has
to be greater than or equal to 0 now
this one it can equal 0 because it's in
the numerator whereas this one here that
we said it had to be greater than but
not equal to 0 cos was in the
denominator so let's subtract 2 from
both sides divide both sides by negative
one remember we multiply or divide both
sides by a negative that inequality sign
changes direction let's go to our number
line here we can see that X has to be
less than or equal to two okay but it
can't equal one so it's less than or
equal to two but it can equal one so
when we write our intervals now we want
to work from left to right or low to
high and you can see this is from
negative infinity all the way up to 1
not including 1 Union 1 to 2 and it
includes 2 so we're going to use the
bracket so that's our domain for the
last one and you got it so if you're
enjoying my videos subscribe to the
channel this channel is all about
helping you to raise your grades so you
can pass your class and go on and pursue
your dreams and hopefully make learning
math a lot less stressful I've got links
in the description below if you want to
check out a more organized list of my
videos specifically for precalculus to
help you chapter by chapter works for
these different topics so check that out
otherwise I look forward to seeing my
future videos and I'll talk to you soon